INTELLECT.
AND THAT'S THE ANGLE.
JOINING ME NOW IS DANIEL DAVIS,
A SENIOR FELLOW AT DEFENSE
PRIORITY.
LIEUTENANT COLONEL DAVIS, THERE
ARE ONLY A FEW PEOPLE AND THE
MEDIA ACTUALLY RAISING ANY
QUESTIONS ABOUT THE PRACTICAL
REALITY HERE.
POLITICAL DEFENSE REPORTER ASKE
ON TWITTER WHO ARE THE UKRAINIA
PILOTS THAT WILL FLY THEM.
DO WE KNOW THEIR CAPABILITIES?
I ASK YOU, DO WE KNOW THAT
ANSWER TONIGHT?
>> WE DON'T, THERE IS SO MANY
QUESTIONS WE DON'T KNOW.
MAN, I AGREED WITH EVERYTHING
YOU JUST SAID.
YOU LATE THE SITUATION OUT SO
CLEARLY.
I WOULD JUST ADD ON A COUPLE OF
ISSUES WHICH IT REALLY
HIGHLIGHTS EVEN MORE WHY THIS I
NOT SUCH A GOOD IDEA.
VLADIMIR PUTIN NOT JUST MIGHT
VIEW THIS IN A NEGATIVE WAY, BU
HE HAS EXPRESSLY SAID, VLADIMIR
PUTIN HIMSELF THAT IF ANY NATIO
SINCE FIGHTER JETS INTO THE
AIRSPACE OF UKRAINE AND THOSE
JETS ATTACK RUSSIANS, HE WILL
CONSIDER THAT COUNTRY TO BE A
PARTICIPANT IN THE WAR AND WILL
ACT PROPERLY AND WILL MAY BE
ATTACKED THAT AIRFIELD BIRD
THAT'S WHAT YOU SOW POLAND WHEN
THEY WERE TALKING ABOUT SENDING
THESE THINGS OVER SAID OKAY HOW
ABOUT WE SEND THEM OVER TO
GERMANY AND YOU GUYS CAN BECAUS
THEY DON'T WANT THEIR AIRFIELD
ATTACKED.
JUSTIFIABLY SO BECAUSE ANYTHING
THAT DOES THAT POSSIBILITY OF
TRIGGERING THE ARTICLE FIVE AND
YOU MAY HAVE A WAR WITH THE
UNITED STATES AND RUSSIA.
NATO AND RUSSIA, AND THERE IS
ABSOLUTELY NOTHING IN PROVIDING
THESE MIGS THAT IS WORTH THE
POSSIBILITY THAT THE UNITED
STATES COULD THAN BE IN A WAR
AND INSTEAD OF JUST THE TRAGEDY
IN UKRAINE YOU'VE DESCRIBED SO
WELCOME IT NOW IT MAY BE IN
WARSAW OR SLOVAKIA, OR GOD FOR
BID AT NUCLEAR ATTACK ON THE
UNITED STATES.
NOTHING IS WORTH THAT.
>> Laura: THERE IS A AMERICAN
WHO OWNS MIG 19 OR MAYBE 29, HE
TOLD NBC NEWS THIS.
MAY BE THE ONLY INDIVIDUAL TO
OWN MIG 29 HE SAID THEY COULD
ELIMINATE THE JETS FROM THE
BATTLEFIELD IN A SINGLE SHOT FO
THERE ARE RUSSIAN FIGHTERS I
COULD SEE THOSE MIG 29'S FROM
THREE TIMES FARTHER AWAY.
AGAIN, LIEUTENANT COLONEL,
YOU'RE THE EXPERT HERE, BUT THA
SEEMS LIKE A BIG DEAL, OR AM I
WRONG?
>> THAT IS EXACTLY RIGHT.
EVEN ON THE PRACTICAL COMING YO
KNOW THAT RUSSIA ANTIAIRCRAFT
CAPABILITY IS GOING TO BE
WATCHING ALL OF THEIR RADARS AR
GOING TO BE LOOKING FOR IT RIGH
THOSE THINGS MIGHT GET SHOT DOW
BEFORE THE EVIL LAND IN
UKRAINIAN AIRSPACE.
THEY WILL BE A TARGET.
THAT'S THE REASON YOU HAVE THIS
FRAGILE LARGE FLEET OF UKRAINIA
FIGHTERS RIGHT NOW THAT AREN'T
GETTING IN THE AIR.
5-10 PER DAY AS YOU JUST
MENTIONED THERE A SECOND AGO
BECAUSE THEY KNOW THEY CAN'T GE
THEM UP.
WHAT IS 20 MORE AIRCRAFT IF YOU
CAN'T FLY?
HOW WILL THAT HELP ANYBODY?
THAT IS A HUGE RISK THAT COULD
EXTEND WAR AND ON THE OTHER SID
THERE'S VERY LITTLE TACTICAL
UPSIDE.
IT'S NOT A GOOD IDEA, IT'S NOT
SMART, AND WE SHOULDN'T DO IT.
>> SOMEONE LIKE MITT ROMNEY
PERHAPS OR MICHAEL CALL MIGHT
SAY YOU ARE PLAYING INTO PUTIN'
HAND BY ANALYZING IT THIS WAY.
YOU'RE ALLOWING HIM TO CALL
EVERY TONE.
AMERICA WITHERS ON THE WORLD
SCENE AND THAT EMBOLDENS THE
CHINESE TO DO WHATEVER THEY'RE
GOING TO DO WITH TAIWAN.
HOW DO YOU RESPOND TO THAT?
>> I SAY, YOU KNOW WHAT, THIS I
ACTUALLY LOOKING AT REALITY.
YOU CAN'T MAKE POLICIES BASED O
WHAT YOU WISH WAS TRUE.
RAISED IN WHAT WE HOPED WOULD B
THE CASE.
WE WOULD LIKE TO HAVE UKRAINE
HAVE THE JETS AND THEY HAVE A
DIFFERENCE, THE REALITY IS
YOU'RE TALKING FROM THESE
EXPERTS, THEY ARE TELLING YOU
IT'S NOT GOING TO MAKE A
DIFFERENCE AND IT'S GOING TO AD
A RISK.
I DON'T CARE WHAT PUTIN THANKS
OR WHAT HE THREATENS OR ANYTHIN
ELSE, IT IT IS NOT BASED ON
REALITY, IT'S GOING TO HELP THE
UNITED STATES.
HIM ALL ABOUT TAKING RISKS, I
DID IT IN COMBAT AND I ADVOCATE
THIS AND THIS DOESN'T HAVE A
CHANCE OF SUCCESS.
>> ALSO WE DIDN'T EVEN GET TO
TONIGHT WHETHER IT ENHANCES
AMERICA SECURITY.
THAT'S ANOTHER THING.
IN A VERY IMPORTANT CONVERSATIO
TONIGHT.
ACTUALLY ASKING THE QUESTIONS
MANY OF WHICH WERE NOT ASKED TH
LA